moi je me raccroche à la moto il y a
rien derrière le jour où je rencontrerai
peut-être la femme de ma vie
j'abandonnerai la moto pour une fille on
sait pas parce que on connaît une fille
qu'il faut laisser tomber la moto
[Musique]
voilà on est vendredi soir ici c'est la
place de la Bastille c'est le lieu de
rendez-vous du vendredi soir des motards
de Paris on reste
une demi-heure une heure on vient voir
les amis on se donne rendez-vous ici le
plus souvent pour ressentir après pour
aller se promener pour regarder la
populace
[Musique]
les nouvelles motos des autres voir ce
qui se fait et ça c'était toutes les
semaines c'est toutes les semaines
il y a aucun problème on travaille tous
pour ainsi dire pour ça ça occupe disons
au moins 60% ou 80% pour d'autres du
budget de la vie courante c'est tout
à l'intérieur d'un groupe de
motocyclistes on se retrouve d'autres on
trouve de vrais amis c'est à dire que
par nous on est toute une bande d'une
dizaine de copains mais à l'intérieur de
ces 10 copains j'ai un ami que j'ai
découvert grâce à la moto mais en
général toutes nos conversations et
pour ce qui est mon cas ça revient
toujours à la moto au moins aussi je
suis animé par le l'amour de la moto
mais enfin je n'en suis pas je suis pas
animée de cet amour jusqu'à la
personnaliser ma moto là transformer la
moto comme une
comme un être humain quoi c'est un moyen
à moto il y en a qui se raccroche à la
politique il y en a qui se raccroche à
une une collection de papillons pour moi
moi je me raccroche à la moto il y a
rien derrière le jour où je rencontrerai
peut-être la femme de ma vie
j'abandonnerai la moto pour une fille on
sait pas parce que on connaît une fille
qu'il faut laisser tomber la moto la
jour où tu connaîtras vraiment une fille
qui aura décidé de faire abandonner la
moto peut-être pour elle tu vas vendre
la moto toute manière on peut pas aimer
la moto au départ mais on peut faire
aimer toute manière il est nécessaire
pour un bon équilibre d'avoir plusieurs
passions de ne pas passer toute sa vie
pour une chose enfin pour la moto par
exemple bon il y en a c'est la moto
comme il faisait tout à l'heure il y en
a c'est la politique je pense qu'on peut
avoir plusieurs passions la photo d'un
camarade qui pendant les événements de
Mai 68 avait monté sa moto 4e étage
tout ça de peur qu'on lui vole et pour
la remonter alors vous voyez c'est c'est
pas quand même dans sa chambre
il existe depuis 3 ou 4 ans
effectivement un phénomène moto quelques
chiffres 3000 motos il m'a dit en France
50000 en 72
vendredi soir à la Bastille il régnait
une certaine effervescence les
représentants de l'or était là et le
commissaire du quartier lui-même avait
décidé d'intervenir
je vois que vous êtes en train de prier
les moteurs dans les ailleurs d'aller à
Vincennes qu'est-ce qui se passe
exactement ici il se passe que depuis de
nombreuses années depuis que c'est
passionné de moto se sont installés à la
Bastille les gens qui habitent dans le
voisinage et dans les artères qu'ils
empruntent pour arriver à la Bastille ce
plan du bruit de leur moto alors nous
essayons de les convaincre de se rendre
actuellement sur l'esprit du château de
Vincennes où il n'y a pas de
pas d'habitants dans les dans le
voisinage immédiat et où il ne gêneront
personne mais vous venez ici pourquoi
faire on se réunit on cause on se
retrouve entre camarades
vous venez seulement pour vous retrouver
on vient pour se retrouver mais des
balades non non pas vraiment non on va
pas faire des tapages nocturnes dans les
rues ou quoi que ce soit à part quelques
petits rigolos qui s'amusent à venir en
échappement libre cela nous font du tort
je pourrais acheter pour regarder et des
occasions à prendre ou à laisser c'est
toujours pareil on peut acheter une
bécane un blouson de cuir on voit on
rencontre des copains des gars qu'on a
déjà vu en concentration sur des courses
des vagues qu'on connaît même pas le nom
mais qu'on regarde qu'on connaît qu'on
sert la main c'est tout un peu le marché
aux puces de la moto c'est pas possible
technique un camarade je sais pas on
peut si on a un pépin n'importe quoi on
peut venir ici surtout pour acheter ou
vendre quelque chose ça marche et qui
bouge la moto il nous accuse de faire du
bruit bon il y a les bécanes font du
bruit il y a des voitures qui en font il
y a des camions des cars des marteaux
piqueurs qui pourraient tourner avec des
silencieux mais les entreprises veulent
pas dépenser de pognon pour ça ce moment
on essaye d'empêcher les motards de
rester à la Bastille c'est qu'il y a de
bonnes raisons quoi c'est parce que la
moto prend une serrure d'ampleur parmi
la jeunesse et qu'en réalité bon bon
c'est c'est un phénomène en marge quoi
il y a des gens qui bagnole la plupart
des Français ont des bagnoles et bon la
jeunesse bon elle s'est repliée sur la
sur les motos et ce qui se passe c'est
que bon bon
ça évite de s'insérer dans un certain
système quoi c'est à dire bon le métro
boulot dodo tel qu'on l'entend quoi j'ai
pris des Unis évidemment sur 450000
balles je donne environ 18000 francs 180
francs tous les mois de crédit plus bien
sûr les à côté c'est-à-dire l'essence
les réglages et les vidanges qui sont
nécessaires et ensuite j'ai enfin avant
tout je crois qu'il faut le lire j'ai un
salaire de 870 francs par mois ce qui ne
me permet pas beaucoup de choses j'ai
une chambre à Paris que je dois payer
270 francs par mois plus la nourriture
enfin à la fin du mois il reste pas
grand chose si je veux sortir
c'est la nourriture qui passe puisque
bon on va tous les soirs c'est le
sandwich perpétuel le bon sandwich le
hot-dog à 2 francs mais les
concentrations surtout l'hiver ça
m'intéresse donc je préfère me passer de
manger pour pour sortir un petit peu
pour me retrouver avec des copains et
puis j'aime ça c'est tout
un loisir parmi d'autres la moto la
bande de la Bastille comme on l'appelait
vient d'être repoussé jusqu'à la
périphérie de Paris elle a le droit de
se réunir désormais tous les vendredis
soir sur l'esplanade du château de
Vincennes
maintenant à Vincennes vous étiez la
Bastille avant non ah oui on est à la
Bastille depuis
maximum 7 ans qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
alors il s'est passé c'est à dire que
les d'après la police la préfecture etc
ils ont pensé qu'on faisait trop de
bruit raison officielle bon c'est vrai
que il y a des quelques motos qui
s'amusent à rouler échappement libre etc
ça fait du bruit enfin dans l'ensemble
moi je pense que c'est pas la véritable
raison
c'est qu'ils ont envie d'avoir un espèce
de Paris résidentiel avec des beaux
quartiers pas de jeunes dans la rue
et des jeunes en moto par des deux cuirs
comme ils disent sur des gros cube
toujours comme ils disent parce qu'il
paraît que ça fait bien c'est une grosse
moto c'est une grosse traduit
il fait froid il y a rien il y a pas de
café on peut pas s'abriter d'abord on
peut pas s'abriter ensuite c'est très
mal éclairé ensuite il y a du gravillons
donc risque d'accident ensuite les
voitures arrivent à n'importe quelle
allure sans à comprendre toujours risque
d'accident
enfin en fait ça ça nous intéresse pas
il y a pas de signalisation non plus
donc vite pas seulement les moteurs une
opération nettoyage à votre avis non
seulement pour la Bastille mais enfin
pour tous les quartiers comme de
Vincennes à la nation de l'époque de la
Foire du Trône qui était renvoyé au bois
de Vincennes comme la Fête de l'Humanité
comme tout ce qui provoque un
rassemblement ou un attroupement deux
jeunes plus ou moins avec des vêtements
qui sortent du costume en fait tout ce
qui provoque un attroupement ils veulent
présenter un Paris propre un pari démuni
de tout ce qui représente la jeunesse
qui n'est pas à l'usine et qui et qui
sort le soir parce que nous sentit de
notre boulot parce qu'on travaille
également et ben on a bien le droit de
sortir si on n'a pas envie de s'acheter
une voiture je pense que c'est notre
droit
[Musique]
on a fait des réunions et tout ça et on
s'est mis d'accord
pour protester et vous avez une réponse
d'abord les gens emploient le terme
voyou à tort et à travers parce que à
l'époque où il y a eu réellement des
voyous à Place de la Bastille je vous
dis ça remonte à 7 ans jamais personne
n'en a parlé et pourtant il y en a eu
jamais personne n'en a parlé quand elle
a conduite des moteurs dans Paris moi je
me suis aperçu d'une chose c'est que les
trois quarts des types qui conduisent
des motos sont très prudents parce
qu'ils ont pas envie de tomber ils ont
pas envie de casser la machine vous
allez retourner la Bastille quand même
un jour non vous allez reprendre la
Bastille ah oui oui on a bien
l'intention de non seulement d'y
retourner mais de pas la quitter
messieurs dames qu'est-ce que vous
pensez déjà qui font de la moto
des moments
qui roulent normalement
ultime dérange pas les gens par le bruit
comme certains font surtout à des
certaines heures alors là ça va ça va
très bien
de la moto mais quand il en faisait il
partait assez loin du quartier mais je
pense qu'ils doivent s'amuser son jeunes
je les comprend très bien mais faut
penser aussi qu'il faut un peu de bruit
la nuit
c'est très intéressant pour les jeunes
vous n'êtes pas contre non
[Musique]
je pense qu'il est agréable de faire de
la moto mais en dehors de Paris parce
qu'effectivement moi chez les
motocyclistes qui passent sous mes
fenêtres le vendredi soir et je trouve
ça extrêmement désagréable ça devient un
fléau quoi mais je trouve qu'ils font
vraiment du bruit et qui nous empêche de
dormir la nuit enfin c'est bien faut
bien que je ne s'amuse
vous n'êtes pas contre les gens qui
s'amusent
mais pour les jeunes c'est bien c'est
bien seulement pour les choses qui font
des avantages de pistes pour les pour
les faire circuler un endroit d'abord
pour pouvoir s'expliquer premièrement
une intérêt quelconque ils ont mis
personne il faut leur donner un endroit
spécial parce que
il faut trop trop d'abris c'est énorme
pour les gens à de mon âge et ça ça
c'est trop énervant vraiment il y a des
jeunes qui font de la moto ce sont des
voyous pour vous ou pas
[Musique]
il y en a beaucoup qui travaillent pour
payer leur petite moto leur plaisir
pourquoi c'est des gens comme les autres
c'est des gens comme les autres
la recette elle est simple au départ une
mobylette toute nue toute bête des
pièces récupérées à droite et à gauche
et à la sortie des vitesses sympathiques
on reste loin du record du monde 178
km/h mais tout de même à 14 ans ça
décoiffe
tu veux que je te parle en vitesse
compteur voiture ou chrono
c'est une mobylette ça fait 49,9 cm3
c'est là elle a un qui sent dessus un
kit sans carbu de 21 les mages
électroniques et tout et puis
théoriquement elle doit atteindre les
130 voitures
ça vous gêne pas ah non pas du tout
j'entends rien du tout non
parce que pas
la bloqué
bah je suis passé sous un camion une
fois quoi j'ai le bras cassé franchement
beaucoup de blessés quelques morts à
Vincennes alors on part à la Bastille
tous les vendredis soirs mais là bonjour
l'ambiance il y a déjà les motards les
vrais et comme disait le poète chacun
chez soi et les motos seront bien gardés
ouais ça dérange
à Vincennes les mobylettes les motos à
la Bastille d'accord c'est le slogan
voilà
[Musique]